welcome to this video
yeah this is a new episode of the modern
classic series which presents
spectacular interesting games from the
last roughly 20 years 25 years so
relatively modern games that still have
the potential are already our classics
and will be looked at for years to come
after three games some that are already
presented that that I really very well
know now get to some game that is also
not unknown but it's not played by
absolute top players where you recognize
the names instantly we had like Anand
Ivonne shock and Yusupov those top
players like top 10 or similar or even
won championship level and those two
players here involved in the game are
kind of regular grandmasters at the time
when this game was played um the white
player Gregory server was rated slightly
below 2600 elo and disappoint Nikola
Edith you honest Nicola it is from
Greece he was on than I am at the time
International Master with two for 40
rating so it's not like we're looking at
large championship candidates here but
they created an absolutely astonishing
game that I am yeah always
it always has been one of my favorite
games because I think also because of
the way M I I met this game so to say it
was played in 1993 so almost 20 years
ago which is yet distinctly pre-internet
era so we didn't have any way of getting
chess information back then
besides magazines and this game was
featured in a German chess magazine that
I got and it didn't have any annotations
or even I don't think it even had
a picture diagram of the game so I
looked at this and I wasn't really
expecting what to see and if you look at
the game you'll see that you're really
astonished but what what happened in the
game and if you especially if you don't
expect that something special is going
to happen so let's see him what happens
um sapper opened 1c form and with some
order we arrived at a regular Kings
Indian yeah here white of course has a
huge choice of lines here sir played
Knight to e2 which is one of the less
common lines against Kings Union still
it's quite interesting the idea is to
get the knight to g3 and their form
fortify the four point the night on g3 m
on the other hand it's not exactly a ya
dream piece in relation to this pawn on
d6 s those natural squares are blocked
but it's an interesting way to play and
it has some distinct ideas we'll see
what happens black plate and not beat
his heavy delays castling this is
because quite often if black castles and
this kind of setups let's just put
something on the board quickly then
White has sometimes even IDs was h4 h5
and this is why black e and this game is
reluctant to Castle he simply delays
counseling and starts with not be g7
yeah okay white gave us an Archie 3s
intended and again black doesn't castle
he plays c6 and this way prepares play
on the Queen side with coming b5 it
should be - yeah white preparing
cancelling and black plays a6 as
mentioned to get this Queen side play
going yeah black some development of
course is a bit slow is spending lots of
time upon use white plays Bishop e3 and
now h4
so this is some a bit of a weird mixture
of queenside play and play on the
kingside yeah this intends to disturb
the the white night with age form or
maybe provoke and move like h4 from
white of course he doesn't doesn't
comply he just replies f3 I don't really
like this h5 ideas so much but it's
probably probably still okay f3 to
bolster the scent and also um yeah to
create a square on f2 will see later
while this is important yeah black now
switches back to the b5 idea and white
plays c5 which is often a good reaction
to to this kind of b5 moves and the
King's onion there there various other
ideas a3 sometimes possible but after
that you have to reckon with this kind
of ideas like this black gets the pawn
back and it's not quite sure if this is
a good structure for white so a3 is
something need to be cautious with
sometimes you can also play before just
stop this before advance um but here it
is a bit a bit early as why it hasn't
even canceled yet so I don't think it is
such a great idea to play this black
probably cannot refute it immediately
but it's a bit too bitter early c5 is so
the most the mattock move really it
gains space on the Queen side and
possibly intends to take on d6 after
which white would have found an extra
pawn in the center so let's say black
butchers castle for argument's sake then
white would take and after this would
have fun comfortable advantage not like
a huge advantage but it's still a good
center this is also why black reacts
differently he just took on c5 White's
and recaptured and like went Queen c7
yeah this is some pretty normal square
for the Queen here
taking a look at those squares and
supporting player on the dark squares
why just canceled a black went H form
and now we see why why they also played
the Move f3 with Knight H 1 2 f2 will
get them a good square for the knight f2
is really a good square as it controls
important squares around the king at
sort of a king defender and it also can
be used further on d3 to get some
offense on the Queen side going on after
the knight is simply is simply a well
positioned it looks funny on h1 but ok
need some time it's a close game yeah
here I think I'm like play Knight h5
right
intending probably Knight to f4 this is
one that the Queen here supports so what
takes away the square yeah here's a
critical moment in this game because
here black had had an interesting
alternative which would have prevented
the the game continuation but it's a
very young yeah committal move that
black would play now and I think the
move which is difficult for humans to to
go for if you look at this with the help
of a of an engine of the with a computer
and you can pretty easily say alright
this might be OK for black but it's so
not easy for a human to to come up with
this in from my suggestion here would be
m and supported by by the computer which
b9 if would be 95 the idea being to use
c4 as a possible square for the knight
and this can also be supported with
Bishop e6 the yet thing is is that black
it doesn't put anything in the center
and pawn wise and it always looks like
he could be punished with the move like
f4 but it doesn't seem like this is
really am
and this is really possible and it's a
very tricky move I mean this can easily
lead to white problems just for example
if you would look at 9f to here which
looks like a very natural move black
can't play h3 which said set some a
great trap because the the natural reply
that you kind of would make instantly in
a blitz game its g3 and then after
Knight takes g3 black wins instantly as
this even leads to a checkmate and a
couple of moves it's a rather brutal
answer so you get this at some yeah it's
a quick put made to come checkmate
of course some white can delay it better
I can play this move but alright at
least this is it's good enough but just
just a terrible way to lose the game
quickly h3 is very annoying move okay
why doesn't need to play understand I
have to move but what should you play
instead yeah let's say I'm on f4 there's
even though this Knight g4 move with
which is quite annoying black simply has
played with his pieces those those
pieces are active so I'm f4 is also not
great and a normal-looking move like
rook e1 black and play we should be 6
and therefore gain this is the square
for real on c4 that they be 3 2 to cover
this and lighter than simply castles
yeah it's not um it's not great for
white I mean white it's not not better
here I think it's it's probably around
equal but a very dynamic position of
course like it's got active pieces but
White has still potential in the center
with f4 at a later stage
so I'm 95 was a very good alternative
you played me 5 though and this is some
very ambitious move the idea as we see
now 9f2 9f8 this was the idea he wants
to get this passive nylon d7 around to
e6 and to d4 suddenly am a strategically
desirable regrouping the only issue with
this is that it takes time of course um
black Kia still could play not a form to
avoid what is coming so I think white
would be slightly better here simply d5
is not a bad move strategically as
mentioned as it tries to clamp down on
the d4 square but it's simply less
dynamic than this ninety five idea white
should be slightly better here we'll
play on the queenside with before and of
course a4 finally attacking the spawn um
yeah I think why should be slightly
better but it's nothing nothing special
really 9f8 however is risky and white
has a very forceful continuation now
which interestingly enough is
immediately spotted by the computer a4
before and ninety five is the instant
reaction of of Houdini which I wasn't so
sure about before I had that before I
checked it really and but he it
immediately recognizes that white gets
gets a strong play here yeah why is this
move so strong and it's also fairly
typical move first of all black needs to
take it we can we can simply put it on
the board
it's clear that black cannot yeah move
the Queen here where where would it go
you would go to b6 or simply take the
pawn if everything else fails so takes
and of course the pawn retakes yeah this
kind of position um yeah this is a very
strong compensation for white and this
is because first of all those two pawns
obviously very strong and will advance
quickly it's all happening near blacks
King which is very important if like
let's say I'm you would switch
the king of the rook yeah like a magic
castle in here King on h8 rook on yet
probably this isn't so great for what I
mean it's what if that it's not
completely clear I would say but yeah
the bad King position is really
interesting a really decisive effect oh
yeah and of course White has another
very strong idea this is not e46 this is
hanging also yeah and as mentioned the
King position is affected but very often
if white would get a second point let's
say before imagines to play even before
later then those two points would be a
yeah enough on on their own to provide
compensation it's now very difficult for
black to to defend he played f5 which is
probably the the toughest defense I also
looked a bit at night f6 CM simply you
need to control a 494 you cannot allow
unpunished um yeah and here white has
some more than one interesting
continuation one good move is probably
ninety four even just threatening this
and black would probably take it yeah
now you have strengthened your pawn
Center here it's all beautifully
supported those pawns will not fall
quickly and white has a very simple um
attacking idea which is Bishop c4 and d6
getting on f7
and the other idea of course simply is
to push the pawn to c6 and d6 note that
if a pawn would appear on c6 this Knight
is basically dead it cannot move
anywhere okay to h7 but where do you go
after you meant to h7 so white has some
very strong compensation here we can
continue this line for a bit and let's
say black inserts this one to get a pawn
yeah White's King g3 and then trying to
regroup the night let's say nine HTML
than g6 Queen c6
and Bishop c4 and yeah this is too much
it's also threatening Bishop d5 picking
up the rook so I'm like it's pretty much
forced to go with this
after which white can can even them
yeah transpose it to this kind of kind
of ending now and this is probably a
relatively an easy technical task for
white to win with the pawn and
the pawn on c5 and likes a precarious
King position why does some clearly
better probably winning it's just one
sample line white has various other
ideas to continue for example instead of
d6 there's also this move which isn't
isn't entirely clear just intending to 6
even allowing castle it's not it's not
clear if this is probably even stronger
so White has a very strong compensation
he went for f5 though which is quite
natural just blocking eform medium yeah
mechanically for this night but white
just continued with d6 gaining a tempo
on the Queen and yeah now the Queen has
some two principles principled squares
it went to c6 in the game I also had a
look at Queen a5 protecting that before
pawn and asking white okay how do you
continue now I'm just I'm just going
away from those pawns yeah in fact White
has again more than one good
continuation it's in fact a problem here
to to choose so which which one you
really want to play I give you one
sample line which is Bishop c4 the idea
being to play Queen d5 going on f7
and this could continue at 4:25
threatening this very terrible check and
then checkmate only seven so Queen he
had 27 mate
okay and the rook is saying so Luke a7
and Bishop d2 and yeah help like a belly
can move one possible idea is this check
and Queen b6 quite a funny
transformation of the position but if
you look at this just briefly it simply
leads to a disastrous position for black
maybe you can can continue fighting here
but it's very very tough White has got
oops
naughty for coming Bishop to before just
getting this pawn and yeah probably
black would need to to just drop the e
pawn and activating activating the PCM
something like something like this for
example and yeah you don't want to
continue the slide even further it's
already close to 10 moves deep b7
probably and six will be falling it's
it's very strong these pawns are just a
great compensation in the game he went
to 36 and if you look at this position
first you're not quite sure probably how
to how to continue it's so fairly closed
and black has protected protected those
square so g7 check leads to nothing but
in fact um White has another very
effective blow which she really showed
them yeah I take take notice off here
because this is a fairly a fairly common
idea of course it's rather unusual to
have those pawns here but the general
idea happens happens quite often white
now played Bishop b5 which is very very
strong sacrificing yet another piece
and the ideas after 8xb five what else
just recapture and then you've got a
sort of double attack attacking the
Queen and the rook on a one attacks the
rook on h8 and then this is a fairly
common maneuver that you have played a
four a five is plug and then have this
Bishop b5 move setting up this this
can't double attack after it is taken
yeah what should like do now he needs to
protect the rook young you would think
so what move probably queen b7 he didn't
play this he didn't play Queen b7 but
let's see what would happen
just c6 young and it's it's an absolute
steamroller what what else Queen b8
covering the rook and then white can
simply play b6 and you've got an
absolute absolutely marvelous picture
here with the three points on be 66 and
musics which simply will will ya
crush like it's no way to to defend this
position just a very very nice looking
set up here yeah black cam therefore
cannot really protect the rook so he
decided at the end to capture on b5 and
give up the room so why just took it and
yeah look looking at this now you'll see
that from a material point of view why
does actually doing quite okay
he's got he won back one rook here and
he's got six points against him against
five points so just from material point
of view it's not a big problem for white
at all it doesn't really ya have
someting sacrificed but which he really
is not the main thing here the problem
is this now how do you protect the
bishop even and yeah black went for
coincidence which is the relatively best
move if you would protect the bishop on
with Queen b7 this movers is super
strong
a scent coming with tempo just compared
with the game in the game he went to c6
Andrew k1 and him Asics isn't such a
such a big threat but with the Queen on
b7 Brooke a seven and just deadly yeah
so we had this position in the game and
yeah black went and played f4 which I
think it's the best try therefore simply
traps this Bishop and it's just along
the philosophy that Wow if you're under
huge attack you should grab every
material that comes your way
unless you think that it loses by force
of course but if you don't see a force
loss then you should simply take
everything I think this is often a good
attitude of course if you see a way to
return the material and get rid of the
the opponent's attack this is also a
good option but yeah I'd rather get
attacked with an extra rook then yeah
without having any extra material so he
went f4 and in fact he didn't have a big
alternative if you would look at let's
say ninety seven white just enforces the
just reinforces here with ninety three
and take on before these these pawns are
just are just deadly strong it's no way
that black him keeps us together while
he'd play therefore as mentioned and
yeah how this white continued he just
played rook one to 87 getting on the
seventh and installing two very strong
rooks you don't see that too often even
though they're after 24 moves so rupees
seven is a possible idea and this is
just one idea of course also there's it
has another very very tough firm motif
here for black what would happen if like
takes the pawn he didn't do that but
of course you need to look at this maybe
this is a good point where you can pause
the video and try to find the move now
for yourself alright I'm going to show
it now what now has a very strong point
go into d5
just a beautiful move yeah black and can
grab the night and now I can try to find
a move to a white immediate check made
and you won't succeed really Queen takes
d5 of course just second Queen takes d5
it's rather simple and a nice mate with
the two rooks but the thing is what
should like to white is just threatening
to take the Queen you have no way to to
cover it and of course you're
threatening other stuff we have 727 for
example black simply has to move he will
get mated lose the Queen or probably
everything yeah everything at the same
time so Queen d5 is just the killing
move and also the killing yeah probably
killing threat yeah
if black doesn't take this is also why
he plays Knight to d7 in anticipation
for the for the Queen move as now Queen
d5 of course isn't possible black can
just take it has gained TF 7 square the
knight has blocked the same rank
so Queen d5 is not not the way to go but
if you look at the position a little bit
deeper then you see that Queen d5 is
still an important idea and white in
fact went on with another sacrifice he
sacrificed already a knight on d5 a
bishop on d5 and now the exchange on c8
yeah not much choice black needs to grab
it and now Queen to d5 the idea just a
thought
white and waits here on on the white
squares and yeah 25 to 6 is quite some
threat what should like do in the game
we grab the bishop
in fact he didn't have any big big
improvement yet she would go here white
would simply give a check and then
played the strong move Knight to e4 with
the idea to in sorry involved the knight
in the indie attack and gap like black
and snow no way to defend this just an
example threatening mate Queeny aid and
rook aid and you'll meet it on f7 no way
to prevent it
yeah Knight f6 really doesn't doesn't
help um we can also have a look at Queen
e8 just for example then white can
simply exchange even know it takes c6
and those pawns yeah will kill black
it's simply too much I mean white will
even get a new Queen probably it's not
like you just regain your material
simply not defensible got those dead
pieces also okay so what did black do he
grabbed on is free which is certainly
the the way to go here superb
just gave the check on his six which is
enough to win the game and it's also the
most aesthetically pleasing way to
continue the computer actually am shows
that 93 wins even quicker but this is
some not very interesting really from
from yeah from an aesthetic point of
view as what what you played is just
much nicer okay let's see what happened
you played Queen e6 check of course King
of Ages the only move as this is just
just checkmate oh yes happening so must
go here and now what continued rook
takes these heavy so just taking this
and threatening mate and you're leaving
the night here
all free again black of course just to
get it with the check it's was checked
so need to take it and King everyone
this is important of course if you would
take here he would spoil all your
efforts and after Queen takes e5 black
would even win here with with both made
even yeah it's not not just a couple of
checks like will win with with the check
made even the problem is some that
knives III sometimes this is an idea I
can show you one one sample I just just
to to show this this argument this is
the problem and at the end it's
checkmate just one line and yeah one
mistake and spoil the whole game yeah of
course he didn't he didn't fall for that
the game we just played King f1 but
still you need to be cautious and
calculate all this because look at this
year black also has a check here but if
you if you then take it's it's another
story as some of course as of course
black doesn't have a useful check here
like we take c5 check still something to
calculate black has a move here in fact
he doesn't need to resign
he's got 22 need to calculate all this
beforehand and now c6 enter this is
indeed winning for white as the C pawn
promotes it's no way to to prevent this
what should like do is totally tied up
let's say King here and then White has
the important move rookie 7 attacking
the the night and then pushing the C
pawn and this is this is winning for
white for example this
and the porn some ponds decide rook
takes six now threatens and black has no
way to prevent it you know all this you
needed to calculate them it's not can
easily overlook a move like we need to
and okay yet is winning he did calculate
everything correctly but it's not very
easy to do this so I'm what happened in
the game black played twenty eight and
now you are again to think all right
that's white maybe sacrifice that be too
much he sacrificed them basically honest
pieces now and what what is the big
point now what doesn't have fun any
check and how to continue really okay
the first idea might be rook to e7 but
then there's this check again and this
is very similar to what I have shown
that we form like now has a winning
attack even with mate so it's not rookie
seven what are you doing then yeah well
white had really done a magnificent job
of calculating all this lines
he played rook f7 sacrificing yet
another piece yeah black needs to take
it this is easy clean CA check Queenie
eight-hour all only moves and now g7 so
it this is the point of all this
the queen is detect and black has no
other move then then this King f7 after
which white free gains here the Queen
and premium promotes only eight and now
what what what do we have now black has
got those three pieces for the Queen but
the Queen in fact supports the seat bond
and the C pawn will will promote now
but it's not without its little kinds of
tactics again queen bee seven check and
black replied with the natural move rook
d7 yeah and what is white doing now yeah
okay so it's a bit much to call the Siq
win sacrifice but he just played c6 that
allowed the queen to be taken as then
the b-pawn would simply promote so black
cannot take here as this is very easy
for white just promoting the Queen so
what did he do a play before which since
a little trap you always need to be
cautious still if white would take now
only four which would be huge a huge
mistake like him take and play we should
be five and this way stopping the pawn
so black wins easily now so always
cautious he false had some yeah sort of
the last trap but white can play c7 and
intend to promote black played III it
looks a bit dangerous said so so um
something might go wrong
yeah let's have a quick look he played
25 now but what would happen if white
would promote EI e to King takes and
mate so black has still one big threat
here this is why played Queen d5 check
and yeah now black has very few options
what what to do we need to go here
otherwise I simply promote with check or
have the the rook yeah for the taking
so let's say he I can just take and
promote with the check or going back
it's this is very simple so black needs
to go to f6 yeah in fact here he quickly
repeated moves to gain a bit of time
on the clock and here finally played
screen takes a sound check King takes
and another queen so we've got two
promotions in this game
e8 Queen and c8 Queen so it's me double
Queen sacrifice if you want to call it I
call it dead so why just got another
Queen and now it's against just two
pieces and those pawns and okay you need
to be being just a little bit of
cautious here that you don't allow some
very silly trick with the pawns black
played them Bishop h6 now protecting
this and white went with a check now
this was to get to this g6 porn 22 now
the last trick Hampi just just not take
here because of just this fork what of
course needs to take here and again be
cautious not it not only two but kingi
one and after King e1 ya like a black
resigned the game as he has no way to to
continue really if you want to keep your
palm you need to play this and for
example after the check
g3 this pawn will fall next move and
yeah black water simply loose against
the Queen so this is really a kind of
fireworks game where white sacrificed so
much material we can just just go
briefly to this it started with this
Knight sacrifice then he then it gave
away a bishop so two minor pieces okay
we gained the rook letting the the
bishop hang on III after F forbs after a
form
look to a seven exchange SEC sacking the
bishop also the knight also got
sacrificed and now the rook so he
basically sucked all his pieces to at
the end promote two pawns to the C pawn
so the e pawn here on the 8th and now
the second pole needs to be promoted ok
and you've got got yet another Queen so
we had three Queens in this game for
what yeah very spectacular game which I
really liked them and I was I know I was
totally stunned by this as I am looking
at this years ago in this chess magazine
which didn't really tell me beforehand
that I'm that I'm about to witness such
fireworks in a game so yeah I hope you
enjoyed this and I'll continue this
series of course with with them
new episodes just like let's say roughly
every two weeks and also just like I
find it yeah it's about time that I need
to to to find to make videos at the
moment as I'm in the process of moving
to to a new apartment and this is really
really time-consuming so I'm doing like
a painting walls and and doing carpets
on the floor and so on
it's an quite some work so it will be a
little bit a little bit less of chess
videos in the next next two three four
weeks so trying to keep frequent updates
but it possibly won't be BM yeah it
probably won't be your daily videos next
couple of weeks
alright thanks for watching and I hope
to be back soon with with new videos